we got another chart the bitcoin supply
and demand model uh this bitcoin supply
and demand model ended up overlaying
three things on top of each other so you
can see the squiggly line is the bitcoin
price the blue line is the supply model
the stock to flow and then the pink line
is the demand model uh it's basically
taking the mobile phone s-curve and
applying it here in a logarithmic
fashion and so when you start to look at
this what you realize is um you know
again it's been really really really
accurate now one of the things that i i
think is important to call out and it
appears fidelity's calling out here is
that the mobile phone s curve adoption
actually tailed off at some point so it
kind of broke away from the model itself
will that affect price will that change
the way that the stock to flow model
works we just don't know right but as
you can see it basically all the way
through a hundred thousand dollars that
mobile phone uh s-curve adoption
continues to overlay on top of the stock
to flow and then it starts to break off
before it gets to a million dollars in
the stock to flow so it's really
interesting to start kind of evaluating
uh how this stuff works you can make an
argument that actually uh the mobile
phone s-curve adoption is going to be at
a slower rate than let's say the bitcoin
and crypto adoption because the bitcoin
crypto world is being built on top of
the internet which is built on uh also
on top of the mobile phones and and uh
the connectivity that that's provided in
the world you could also argue that just
there's plenty of people who already
have in the developed world
other financial services and they're not
going to go adopt this again this is how
markets get made people are betting
literally billions if not trillions of
dollars in totality on these questions
but this is data that fidelity is
showing last thing is the s-curve
adoption
i think this was also
in their
presentation here and what you can see
is the red is the broadband
subscriptions yellow is internet users
blue is mobile phone subscribers then
you have bitcoin active address count
and then you have the bitcoin address uh
count of balances over zero and what you
see is that we are definitely watching
very rapid growth uh but nowhere near as
deeply penetrated yet as the internet
users the mobile phones or broadband
subscriptions not surprising
but what but what you can definitely
tell is there's a much
steeper climb to those adoption curves
right you're being built on top of these
legacy technologies that everyone uses
and so it's something to keep paying
attention to i think
fidelity should get tons of credit for
being very early to this understanding
it doing everything from mining to
providing products and services to their
customers uh but again seeing a hundred
million dollar uh price point on a chart
that fidelity's showing their customers
i think would be very surprising to
people um and maybe we'll try to get
timur on here to uh to come in and talk
to us a little bit about it but uh but
fascinating yeah i mean a 100 million
dollar bitcoin price is unfathomable i
mean the entire stock market is 75
trillion
most people
yeah look that that's like 100 million
is what year do they have that hitting
in 2035
yeah that's
i think the the stock to flow model
might be
bullish
are you not a believer in 100 million by
2035
100 million by 2035 no
john
100 million by 2035
it's not that i don't believe in the
technology or uh kind of that it's going
to appreciate in price but if you just
look at the total worth of everything in
the world
then that doesn't really seem believable
okay
john wait i think there's an under 50
chance that it is a hundred million
dollars a coin john a probabilistic
thinker i like to see it very
intelligent i'm leaving i'm leaving just
in case all he basically said was i
don't think it will be real quick before
we move on can we pull up the stock to
flow one more time so what this is
saying is uh that we are going to hit a
hundred thousand dollars uh by basically
the end of 2021
believers or non-believers in that so
far again not financial advice just
opinion by the end of 2021 believer
believer john
yes i'm a believer okay over 50
okay i am also a believer that we are
gonna see a hundred thousand dollars
before the end of 2021. now this chart
next shows that we will hit 1 million
dollars by the end of i think
2025. uh it's a little hard to see go
back one uh there matt
um if we go to this chart i think it's
the end of
what is that end of 2025 uh we would hit
one million dollars a coin believer or
non-believer are you gonna answer any of
these questions i just said i believe
100k we're gonna go one by one okay um a
million dollars by 2025. by the end of
2025 so before 2026. basically after the
next halving yeah
yeah look i think these are the ones
that are
more believable
is that a yes or no he's going one by
one to get you to 100 million no okay so
we believe i believe a million after the
next halving
do you yep john
oh okay we were losing john a little bit
john john might be able to go right at
50
all right john's tailing off on that one
now last one that i'm going to ask we're
not forget 100 million if we go back to
the chart here we can see that by the
end of
2029 i believe it looks like uh
so before 2030
10 million bitcoin
so by the end of the decade 10 million
bitcoin
believer non-believer
i think that's where it starts to break
okay
we lost john around a million we lost
joe around 10 million i'm actually a
believer 10 million by the end of the
decade because that would basically be
gold's market cap by the end of the
2020s we will have eclipse gold's market
cap i think okay so now let's go to
let's go to 100 million a coin you'd
have to pour in gold the entire stock
market real estate
derivatives everything you could imagine
into bitcoin's price to get it there
plan b has hasn't he even said or i
don't know if it's a he or she i guess
it's a he right uh has he even said that
hasn't he said that the model was broken
not that it's broken now but he believes
that there's a chance that it could be
break in the future like basically it
can't go up yeah it can't go up
up forever in terms of the dollar price
given that eventually if that happened
the dollar price wouldn't matter and it
would everything just be priced in
bitcoin right so like at some point like
it doesn't apply uh but here's what i
will explain to you so you said the
stock market today is 75 trillion yep
right the stock market before this year
it'll be more yeah it was not 70
trillion of course right and so it's
going to change
so by the end of the decade do you think
the stock market will be 100 trillion
in 10 years will it will it grow 30
percent i mean 33 this year didn't it
right it may it may be worth 100
trillion by the end of next year what's
up guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today if
we're gonna be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you 10 in bitcoin
for free it's that simple head on over
to sofi.com
to get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]